[Applause]
in a largely Christian Conservative
Republican state an unexpected but
undeniable victory for pro-choice
activists
in Kansas tonight and I feel like my
state just showed up and Baldi told me
that they are going to take care of me
and my female friends and everyone that
can get pregnant in the state of Kansas
we are protected tonight there was a
high turnout in this state voting across
party lines if it can happen in Kansas
it can happen anywhere and some believe
it proves the majority of Americans are
on one side abortion is wildly popular
abortion is popular among every
demographic abortion is a procedure that
every part of the country gets and needs
and this vote in Kansas shows us that
when people's access is directly under
attack no matter where they fall on the
political spectrum they will fight back
for those who in June were ecstatic at
the decision to overturn Roe versus Wade
This is a setback it's heartbreaking
it's very heartbreaking I'm I'm upset of
course uh it's unfortunate that it
failed and it failed to the measure that
it did uh there was a lot of
misinformation out there and
um I just it really kind of fuels our
fire to make sure that if we can do this
again that we change our approach
President Biden still in covert
isolation has signed an executive order
I'm going to sign this executive order
right now okay to protect women forced
to travel across state lines for care
the women of America should be protected
their right to make decisions about
their own bodies should be a matter that
we all defend it is in the interests of
the White House to keep this issue on
voters Minds even if the president is
largely powerless to act
Kansas may now become an island of
abortion access in this country but the
decision handed down by the Supreme
Court six or so weeks ago still will
have an enormous impact on women seeking
terminations here and trying to reverse
that could take decades
abortion now seems sure to be a key
election issue in big races here for
years to come Joe Pike Sky News
Washington